from the Carolina Panthers one of my
favorites that I gotten to meet
throughout the years
amazing 10th season in the NFL oh man
jello McCoy you're on the program how
are you gerald hey ten years
yeah won by quick right it's been ten
years since you were asked what type of
underwear you wore by the Kansas City
Chiefs all right at the combine with our
extremely fair Oh Maude I'm so happy for
you being in a spot like Carolina where
it looks like you are a perfect mix to
what they needed I wonder how you feel
in the first few weeks there Gerald I
feel great man I told my wife and a
couple people close to me now say it
publicly career-wise it's one of the
best decisions I've ever made man
starting from top to bottom with a you
know mr. Tepper he's a great a owner you
know and the Glazers were too I'm not
taking away from what the greatest work
of just saying like he's just you know
first year on the team and he's making
big moves man and I'm very happy that he
gave me an opportunity to play here then
you know down the coast Rivera who's
been very welcoming to me since I came
on my visit you know and he has to
change it wasn't just let me be nice to
this guy to get him here and then i'ma
show who I really am he's who you see at
all times is who he is you know he's
very consistent who he is and they've
done a great job of take care of me you
know realizing I played a lot of snaps
and got a lot of wear and tear on my
body so take care of me doing camping
edges that locker room you know it's a
it's a great locker room and I'm just
extremely excited about the future with
how guys work here you know coach
Washington coach Sam they just we work
diligently we work extremely hard here
but we know how to have fun but only at
the right times and I believe that it
will gonna be a big year for us are you
guys talking Super Bowl in that locker
room as those two words I mentioned
that's all the way to talk it's just
super bowl of us mindset and there's a
car going
so if you're anything the background
that's what it is it's okay anyway yes
Super Bowl or bust - and we know all the
time we have here but it's just on paper
you know and on paper it looks great but
we know we got a lot of work to do and
we got a great test for us coming up
going up to the defending champs home
and uh you know getting a little
practice running what did you learn what
have you learned about cam in the few
months that you've been with this
organization that you did not know about
Cam Newton Gerald McCoy what you learn
about him so far oh that I didn't know
yeah there's some things I can't say
there are all positive things but you
know it's very private locker room okay
but it's gonna keep it's probably keep
that yes all positive he here's what I
say about him okay here's what I have
learned which already knew but I'll say
it for the public don't worry there's a
big misconception about who he is and
how he is he loves to have a great time
but he's such a caring guy and he cares
about his teammates always looking out
for his teammates cares about his
teammates and cares about people you
know I had a conversation with him and
he just says you know he he is hard for
him to sit back and see people go
without or see people struggle and I
think a lot of people don't know that
about him how big his heart is and he's
just such a great human
you know everybody looks at all the
antics but this is him he loves to have
a good time and he's unapologetically
10-car mouth dry unapologetically camp
and that's just who he is and he's gonna
be that way and I'm excited to be on his
team got tired of chasing got bet yeah
right there in the division so what's
yeah what's it gonna be like gerald
when you take on the Bucks game - it's
not gonna be circled in any way shape or
form for you why why I don't know I mean
you had you've had nine years there I
mean so many people you know here's what
people are putting Wayne walnut in a
to be okay I'm not the first person who
goes from one team to a division
opponent play the L team once they've
been there for a long time but not you
know this is something that's happened
in history before this is like you know
history breaking news but I think
because of how I went down people are
putting more on it than it should be
I'm not giving any more light here's
what I said about the situation I'm
gonna approach it like any other game
I'm gonna go out there like any other
game and play it like any other game you
know you put too much into one thing you
psych yourself out go out there
underperform and now you worry about
what this person's gonna say that
person's gonna say I'm not worried about
any of it you know those guys always
will be my family regardless you know I
wish them the best but you know week to
week six come up we just gotta go at it
and that's how don't be yeah you know
I'm gonna be calling that game I believe
in London on the NFL Network show so I'm
just trying okay great you know I'll be
there I'll be there in London with you
yeah how good does McCaffrey look like
in practice
well that guy's a weapon you know
there's some people you say well he's
wide receivers and running back he's a
quarterback he's a weapon Christian is a
he getting you know block he can run in
between the tackles he can throw he
threw passed last year he didn't catch
you know I don't think he dropped it he
job thinking that no drops last year he
does not single pass - you know that's
incredible so he's a weapon you know a
lot of people he has this stigma well
Kenny run between the tackles oh yeah
have you watch the tape yeah he can run
between attackers he can do it every day
to retire if you want the return kicks
he could do that he's proven he can do
it there's nothing he really can't do
that we asked him to do and it's great
that he's on our team because he's
really a weapon he's freakishly athletic
even while I let it then you know he's
got to get to see a lot of breakfast
before I let you go Gerald pass
interference is being reviewable this
year would you want holding reviewable
in the trenches would you want that
nah it's a greedy game and you know I
always think the best holders are
without getting caught or the best off
of the line
you know offensive linemen hold it's
part of the game it's our job to keep
them from holding us and it's only
holding if they call it so you know
they'll call it did this not hold it
that's kind of our rule here so now this
is part of the game and you know people
like Eric Donald and myself and such the
Coxes caking short just you know guys
this big it held all time so it's just I
go so I don't think it should be
reviewed man up late again
how's Oklahoma gonna be this year
champion huh let me write that down you
like do you like hurts you like him did
you like him as a Crimson Tide though
Gerald now when he played a right did
you see any a Kyler Murray's second
preseason game what can we read about
calamari and from what we've seen so far
before I let you go Gerald it's a good
preseason game it happens people have
tough games you know I've had games of
our career where you know you like well
think what happened in a preseason then
I went on to make Provost all-pro ceases
its preseason its preseason everybody
people have to understand you don't have
four weeks before your first three
season game you have four weeks before
the first regular season game so within
that process of getting ready for the
season
you have glorified you know scrimmages
so all preseason games are glorified
scrimmage as coaches work on work on
that well now he's seen what it looks
like when you blitz all the time on
pressors on home retainers yes Frank I
have 100% confidence you know and every
week except when they play us so I hope
he does with us
all right last one for you Gerald this
is very important how come you don't
follow me on Twitter anymore did I piss
you off do something I don't know I mean
I see that avatar of a beautiful kid
right there
Deenie 93 yeah yeah if I did it really
with that I know I know I just want to
make sure cuz it you know couple times
I'm like yeah I just want to make sure
that you're you know that uh I'm
following you nuts the I got let's stay
in touch
let's stay in touch all right take care
of yourself thanks for the call really
appreciate you you got that's Gerald
McCoy for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app